batta
[Musique]
poloni pare brise le grand problème
d'homme ça tu as toujours été de fixer
le temps et le tatouage est qu'une
faction sud fixe et le fixer une époque
à votre manière monsieur bruno vous êtes
vous aussi un spécialiste de la peau
pourquoi est ce que les gens viennent se
faire tatouer
ça c'est la question évidemment
classique mais la question à laquelle en
tant que professionnel je ne peux
quasiment pas répondre par des
généralités
ainsi vous allez on va prendre
précisément est ce qui vous vient plus
d'hommes que de femmes
oui 95 % d'hommes 5% dom c'est bien
assez parce qu'elles sont très embêtante
est-ce que c'est plutôt des jeunes
plutôt des vieux le tatouage
réponse si vous voulez un âge
moyens c'est à dire environ et en
moyenne 34 37 ans j'entends par là qu'il
y à des jeunes gens qui sont tentés par
le tatouage foulée ya aussi des
personnes qui ont 70 ans et qui me
demandent de les re tatoué à ce que
c'est à votre avis dans l'ensemble
surtout pour s'affirmer
le tatouage répond à tout un tas de
choses c'est à dire à tous ceux que
l'homme et susceptibles d'imaginer et
d'autres puiser dans le tatouage
d'ailleurs je crois que en considérant
l'hétéroclisme des outils a tatoué qui
ont été utilisés jusqu'à nos jours
ou bien même dans les endroits où les
gens n'ont pas toujours moyen de se
procurer des outils adaptés ils arrivent
à tout de même s'ingéniait à en trouver
ou à en faire et bien cela montre
combien le tatouage est un besoin
revenons raisons pour lesquelles les
gens viennent est ce que il arrive que
ce soit par tradition parce que ça se
fait dans la famille
cela se fait mais surtout dans les pays
anglo saxons c'est ainsi que les deux
président théodore roosevelt était à
tous et qu'un ça se faisait dans la
famille des roosevelt
ça s'est fait dans de nombreuses
familles aristocratiques autrefois mais
disons que en france maintenant la
tradition familiale a complètement
disparu à ce sujet pour les gens qui ne
se font pas tatoués c'est souvent une
marque une preuve d'exhibitionnisme il
est de fait
que dans les années 1930 certains julo
de la bastille rien à montrer si vous
voulez ou n'ayant aucun moyen de briller
voulait montrer des tatouages
c'est très dommage on a extrapolé à
partir de cette constatation pour
substituer à l'ensemble mais à mon avis
c'est une erreur et vous pourrez voir
chez - des médecins des avocats et des
gens de toutes conditions qui n'ont que
faire de montrer dans tatouages ils les
font pour eux et non pas pour s'exhiber
les régions qui viennent avec des
photographies d'individus ou d'animaux
et qui vous disent reprendre ses bras ça
c'est tous les jours tous les jours
c'est tous les jours des portraits le
plus courant ça a été celui de du
général de gaulle il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ont de gaulle sur la peau y en a pas
beaucoup non m'enfin ça m'a été demandé
on m'a demandé brigitte bardot on me
demandait johnny hallyday on m'a demandé
tout c'est quand à monsieur arrivée vous
dit un jeune homme arrive ou demandes
faites m'en une moto sur le ventre
d'accord une dame arrive elle dit je
voudrais un coeur avec le nom de mon
mari dedans vous comprenez pas besoin
d'explications un autre monsieur veut un
dessin d'inspiration biblique
vous comprenez aussi est ce qui vous est
arrivé de vous demander tiens pourquoi
est ce qu'il veut faire ça oui bien sûr
un jour j'ai deux jeunes gens qui sont
venus et qui ce qui est enfin qu'ils
s'étaient promis mariage et bien la dame
s'est fait tatouer le cadenas sur la
poitrine elle monsieur s'est fait
tatouer la clé sur le sien donc voyez
pris séparément
on nageait complètement nuls n'aurait
compris pourquoi j'ai également dans mes
photos là bas vous l'avez vu sans doute
une jeune fille qui s'est fait tatouer
une montre avec une heure précise bien
cette jeune fille gelé d'abord taquiner
comme à mon habitude et elle m'a avoué
que c'était l'heure à laquelle son amour
l'avait quitté et pour elle la vie
s'arrêtait là
oui contre à ce sujet un peu non on
pourra dire qu'il est un clignotant
demoiselle roi tabbee ch vous avez
combien de tatouage madame 4 4 vous avez
commencé tôt 17 ans à 17 ans pourquoi
est-ce que vous êtes fait tatouer parce
que c'est disons aussi des tatouages sur
tous relatifs à mon mari
une preuve d'amour ils ont pour mon mari
qui est également un sentiment de
propriété ils ont fait remarquer c'est
lui qui vous l'a demandé
non non si c'est viennent moi je viens
de vous vous avez eu envie de d'avoir
cette marque de possession vous ne
regrettez pas vous en ferez d'autres je
sais pas en avoir d'autres ou non plus
est ce que vous les montrez facilement
oui sinon sa penderie serre j'ai posé
une question qui est peut-être un peu
discrète supposer qu'un jour vous aimiez
un autre homme
je le ferais manger sera pas enlevée le
dissimuler parce que ça sera comme
grenier disons ce que j'ai fait
actuellement et puis je pense que malgré
tout sera mon mari j'aurais aimé le plus
ça ne rejoint pas l'utilité de charge
après toute façon on se regarde j'ai
fait je garde toujours cette dame un
jour très très distinguée qui est venu
me voir et qui m'a demandé de lui
tatouer une rose entre les deux seins et
qui pendant l'opération pleurer alors je
lui ai demandé si bien sûr c'était moi
qui lui faisait mal elle m'a dit non le
tatouage n'est rien monsieur à côté de
ce qu'il justifie et de m'expliquer
qu'elle avait perdu un petit garçon de 4
ans qui adorait les rosés qui menait
d'ordinaire poser sa tête à l'endroit
précis où je faisais la rose
donc vous voyez dans l'esprit de cette
femme est bien le fait de mettre une
rose à cet endroit là rappelait quelque
chose quelque chose qui était passé et
le tatouage c'est vraisemblablement
souvent pour fixer le temps cette fuite
éternelle pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes
dit si on veut faire termine mon
tatouage chez le serpent qui encercle le
monde l'étape de la ville pour les faire
mettre en couleur avant pour maman et en
noir et blanc on attend la suite
aujourd'hui pour fermer de la couleur
c'est pas votre soldat toile il ya non
ce n'est pas le seul nom c'est le
quinzième seuls 15 tatouage qui
représente quoi tous des motifs biblique
non c'est le seul domaine public que
j'ai tous les autres sont des animaux
défiguration pourquoi ces tatouages bien
cet attachement ça me plaît beaucoup
donc c'est un petit besoin de jeunes
c'est pour me rassurez moi même ça
représente pas mal de
d'animaux qui auront disparu dans
quelques années j'aurais toujours lent
footeuse santé solidaire d'animaux
disparus
je suis contre la sanction dira ce
qu'est ce que ça fait pour vous ça vous
dit accompagné à 51 compagnie ça me
plaît beaucoup
j'aime bien des femmes déshabillées me
regarder une grande glace murale examine
oui à toi d'ailleurs mais est ce que
vous le montrer beaucoup aux autres
n'ont pas tellement trop fortement
présente c'est plutôt pour moi même les
femmes ça les impressionne oui certaines
sont impressionnés d'août note positive
vous l'avez pas fait pour ça au départ
n'ont pas de perdre dans la suite j'ai
j'ai eu une femme quittée israélite et
donc le tatouage que vous voyez à
l'heure actuelle un rapport est celui-là
foyer depuis maintenant j'ai des
sentiments provisoires élite le
phénomène tatouage finalement n'affecte
qu'une minorité de gens en france n'ont
pas vu une minorité une minorité il ya
des miro des minorités nombreux en
france m'enfin quand on pense que ceux
de la guerre de 14 qui sont partis
bouffer du [ __ ] se sont fait beaucoup
d'atouts et quand on veut penser à tous
ceux qui sont qui ont été prisonniers
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale et
qui sont fait beaucoup d'atouts et quand
on veut penser au corps expéditionnaire
d'indochine quand on veut penser à tous
ces bataillons d'algérie dans lesquelles
il était bon de présenter un tatouage
pour être acceptée quand on veut penser
à tous ces gens qui sont fait tatouer en
prison car faut pas les négliger cela il
y en a pas mal à tous ces légionnaires
et à tous ceux qui aujourd'hui vous le
voyez viennent me demander quelque chose
alors si c'est une minorité ma foi
j'ai pas trop quoi vous répondre et vous
vous êtes à tout et ça c'est l'éternelle
question à laquelle je ne réponds jamais
vous m'en excuserez mais je pense que le
tatouage est une intimité et que de ce
fait je n'ai pas répondu
[Musique]